hallo leute heute haben wir einen ganz
besonderen gast hier bei isar germany
nämlich dimitris von easy krieg
willkommen dimitris es ist gut hier zu
sein
hallo leute ja vieles krise kriegt doch
vergeblich
ich freue mich dass du da bist denn wir
wollen heute ein video darüber machen
welchen einfluss die griechische sprache
auf die deutsche sprache hat viele leute
wissen gar nicht dass die deutsche
sprache sehr starke geprägt ist vom
griechischen vom altgriechischen genau
zu sein und ich freue mich sehr dass du
da bist und uns dabei hilft ein bisschen
besser zu verstehen woher diese ganzen
wörter kommen in der deutschen sprache
dem ist wir fangen an mit einem kleinen
überblick was ich sehr interessant fand
als ich dieses thema recherchiert habe
ist dass ich wusste zwar dass es
griechische wörter im deutschen gibt
aber ich wusste nicht wie viele es gibt
und in welchem umfang also wie groß
dieser einfluss ist denn es gibt einmal
wörter die sind früher im mittelalter
aus dem altgriechischen in die deutsche
sprache gekommen
es gibt aber auch wörter die sind über
das lateinische in die deutsche sprache
gekommen und etwas was ich noch nie
vorher aktiv bemerkt habe ist dass es
ganz viele griechische präfix und so
fixe gibt die in der deutschen sprache
existieren und durch die es auch vielen
wortneuschöpfungen neologismen in der
deutschen sprache gibt die eigentlich
also die sind quasi halb griechisch halb
deutsch sozusagen und die gehen wir
jetzt mal durch und zeigen euch wie groß
der einfluss der griechischen sprache
auf das deutsche ist unser erstes thema
sind zum beispiel griechisch
präfix ein paar beispiele sind mikro
makro neo bio öko also es gibt über 50
griechische präfix sie heute noch im
deutschen existieren und auch neue
wörter entstehen mit diesen drei fixen
und gibt es diese ganz also all diese
präfix auch noch in der neu griechischen
sprache ja sicher micro bedeutet klein
makro bedeutet bedeutet bio bedeutet
leben auto ist kommt aus das wort 11
durch selbst und öko kommt aus akkus und
echoes bedeutet haus ein präfix was ich
interessant finde ist zum beispiel das
präfix mega was heißt das im
griechischen einfach bedeutet groß groß
und im deutschen gibt es ganz viele
wörter die mit diesem traffics gebildet
werden und auch viele moderne wörter der
jugendsprache wie zum beispiel megageil
mega stark oder man kann auch einfach
sagen mega also du kannst mir etwas
neues erzählen was total total tolles
total geil ist und ich sage mega gibt es
wird dieses wort heute auch noch ist das
ein cooles wort in griechischen oder
einfach ein ganz normales wort es ist
eine ganz normale sports okay also wir
haben uns jetzt die schon mal die pre
fixe und so fixe angeguckt und haben
gesehen dass es wahnsinnig viel einfluss
gibt es da aus der griechischen sprache
jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein paar wörter
an
ich lese einfach mal vor dem idriss ok
ästhetik scp akademie akw mehr akustik
akustik alphabet alfa mito also ihr habt
immer am ende noch einen vokal hinten
dran wenn die wörter feminin oder
neunter sind wenn sie maskulin sind sie
haben es ja das ist interessant kümmern
sich gut merken dann im griechischen ja
es ist eine große und eine
kostenunterschied zwischen deutsch und
griechisch diese regeln sind sehr stark
ok anarchie anna hier apokalypse
apokalypse dieses wort bedeutet auf
griechische literally weg heißt es
wörtlich
dieses wort bedeutet wörtlich
revelations offenbarung enthüllung
offenbar naja dieses wort ist
interessant butt butt butt jedoch hätte
bedeutet dass käse von chemie chemie
chirurgie mio
chronologie chronologie demokratie hatte
das heißt auf griechisch demokratie
genau demokratie dialekt dialektisch
diaspora wie es bruder dinosaurier
avinos diskothek whisky dieses wort ist
nicht griechisch nicht genau
es ist ein neologismus dieser wörter
sind französisch
über neue ideen oder neue erfindungen
die ja in griechenland sie hatten keinen
diskotheken oder nein
sie haben symposia decken sowohl haben
hatten sie keinen fotografien oder
keinen telefonen aber sie sind alle
griechische wörter sie ja die französin
hat sie haben davon inspiriert das ist
interessant auch telefon ist so ein wort
woher kommt dieses wort telefon sie sind
zwei wörter das erste ist delay es
bedeutet fern und es kommt aus das wort
von i bedeutet stimmung oder fern
stimmen
aber es gibt also griechische wörter die
in anderen europäischen sprachen neu
benutzt wurden also genau so wohl und
dann sind die aus dem die franzosen
haben ein griechisches wort genommen
daraus ein neues wort gemacht und die
deutschen und die engländer und andere
haben das an diesem fall nicht die
franzosen ich glaube es war amerikaner
sie das telefon ist eine amerikanische
erfindung im 19 jahrhundert es war
modisch wenn sie neue erfindungen hatten
die benutzten die altgriechische wörter
weil sie cool das ist das ist ziemlich
witzig ehrlich gesagt ja und heute
nutzen wir haben das in deutschen auch
mit englischen wörtern also wie
wir kreieren neue wörter von denen wir
denken dass sie englisch sind und cool
sind wie zb handy wir nennen unser
telefon handy aber auf englisch gibt es
diesen begriff gar nicht ich weiß ja man
sieht viele wissenschaftliche wörter
also die ganzen wissenschaften wurden in
griechenland geprägt und die begriffe in
viele sprachen übernommen also
eigentlich alle wissenschaftlichen
fachbegriffe aus medizin psychologie
gesellschaftswissenschaften politik all
diese sachen wurden eigentlich aus dem
griechischen übernommen oder ja als auch
die künstler wie theater und musik alles
wichtige alles wichtige in unserem leben
kommt aus griechenland die mieten viele
griechen sagen das und sind sehr stolz
darauf war an
darauf war vom darauf ja aber ich glaube
manchmal übertreiben so winzer
übertreiben wir betreiben wir ein
bisschen ja cool demetrius dankeschön
auf jeden fall dass du dabei warst im
video ich fand das total spannend und
ich finde man hat jetzt auch ganz gut
verstanden wie viele wörter eigentlich
aus dem griechischen beeinflusst sind
also mir war das feuer nicht so klar und
euch wahrscheinlich auch nicht und wenn
ihr lust habt auch mal zu sehen wie das
leben so in griechenland auf der straße
aussieht und wie die griechische sprache
klingt heute im alltag dann solltet ihr
unbedingt mal easy griechisch gruppen
danke schön cool dankeschön dimitris
habe einen wunderschönen tag in athen
und ich hoffe wir können euch bald dort
besuchen und dann werden wir noch mal
ein weiteres video zusammen machen
vielleicht im nächsten jahr
es war eine ehre sein
das freut mich sehr danke fürs zuschauen
und bis bald liebe leute zu süß
[Musik]